these were the odds that the Miami Heat
would win the NBA Finals before the
playoffs started do you know how bad
these odds are not to roast them or
anything but the U.S Men's National Team
had a hundred to one odds of winning the
World Cup the U.S team had a better
chance of beating both Messi and Ronaldo
than the heat had it beating the Bulls
bucks Knicks Celtics and Nuggets the
Houston Texans who are arguably the
worst team in the NFL has 200-1 odds to
win the Super Bowl again better odds
than the Heat hat now that they're in
the finals after becoming the first
planned team to ever make the finals and
the second number eight seed to ever
make the finals their odds are plus 350
to come out on top against the Nuggets
who of you are riding with the heat